merci Laurence Rossignol de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes sénatrice
socialiste de l'Oise vice-présidente du
Sénat rapporteur du texte qui vise à
assurer un nombre suffisant de soignants
par patience hospitalisé on va en parler
évidemment dans quelques instants mais
d'abord on parle de la réforme des
retraites encore plus d'un million
manifestants hier dans les rues du pays
Élisabeth Bank vous l'avez vu elle a dit
en temps de les interrogations et les
doutes suscités par cette réforme et
elle dit que le débat parlementaire
permettra d'enrichir le projet quand
vous
d'abord ce qui est intéressant c'est ce
qui s'est passé hier effectivement moins
de grébine moins de grévistes et plus de
manifestants les gens s'économisent les
grévistes s'économisent ils savent que
la mobilisation va être longue qu'il y
aura d'autres journées d'action et ils
sont effectivement très très déterminés
et ils sont déterminés dans un grand
calme moi j'ai manifesté à Compiègne
dans ma ville 6000 manifestants je pense
que j'avais pas vu ça de mémoire de
compiennois depuis peut-être moins 25
ans et j'ai discuté beaucoup avec les
gens des infirmières scolaires qui
étaient là des ouvriers des employés
c'était vraiment des gens du tertiaire
également on a vraiment une mobilisation
qui est très large de de la France voilà
il faut il faut avoir ça en tête on
n'est pas dans les noyaux durs des
syndicalistes là mais qu'est-ce qui vous
disent les gens est-ce que c'est
uniquement la réforme des retraites ou
ce que la retraite c'est un peu la
goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le vase
d'une colère plus profonde c'est trop
c'est trop trop déjà on a déjà on en
bave déjà c'est dur déjà il y a
l'inflation déjà et en plus ce
gouvernement vient nous dire qu'on va en
baver encore plus longtemps c'est ça que
les gens nous disent et ils le
ressentent ça comme une forme en fait de
maltraitance à leur égard j'en compris
que la réforme des retraites elle est
pas indispensable à l'instant où nous
parlons voilà et qu'elle va dépendre de
plein de paramètres les gens ont compris
aussi que ce gouvernement qui dit fait
baisser le chômage devrait s'appuyer sur
cette baisse du chômage pour être plus
optimiste sur les ressources de demain
de notre régime de retraite par
répartition bref voilà ce que voilà ce
que moi j'ai entendu la position de la
première ministre alors le problème
c'est que c'est 64 ans voilà les gens ne
veulent pas d'un allongement l'âge de la
retraite et le gouvernement est bloqué
sur le report de l'âge donc je veux bien
qu'il y ait des améliorations en plus
moi ça m'amuse quand ils disent enrichir
le texte mais non leur texte n'aurait
pas l'enrichir les gens veulent au
contraire qui ne leur rétrécissent ce
texte ils veulent ils veulent au
contraire qui retire des choses donc
faut faire attention parce que Elisabeth
borde me paraît parfois être très bloqué
très déterminé c'est pas un bras de fer
avec le pays la réforme des retraites et
d'un point de vue je regarde toujours
des femmes
c'est la deuxième femme première
ministre la première Édith Cresson a été
raillé et essorée par le sexisme de la
classe politique ce serait bien que la
deuxième réussisse et qu'elle ne
réussissent pas sur un modèle taschien
voilà c'est on n'a pas besoin d'une dame
de fer en France aujourd'hui c'est ce
qu'elle a aujourd'hui pour vous il faut
c'est le risque pour elle dans cette
affaire là c'est de devenir la dame de
fer et le fait que Emmanuel Macron est
présente de la République lui
juge que dans cette affaire de réforme
des retraites il joue sa son autorité
c'est le problème de Macron c'est pas le
problème de la première ministre elle
est-ce qu'elle doit jouer c'est tout
autre chose d'être celle qui est en
phase avec le pays qui est capable
justement d'entendre la souffrance alors
ça ce que peut-être que je dis va
maintenir les femmes dans cette idée
quels sont dans le Caire qu'elles sont
dans le soin qu'elles sont attentives
mais c'est bien d'avoir une première
ministre qui est attentive
sensible à la souffrance et aux espoirs
du pays on va revenir il y a beaucoup de
choses dans ce que vous nous avez dit
sur le fond mais sur la forme puisque
vous nous avez dit au début que les
manifestants que vous avez rencontrés
hier il se prépare à tenir sur la durée
il y a deux autres journées qui ont été
annoncées déjà la semaine prochaine
mardi et samedi prochain en grande
partie dans les vacances scolaires pour
certains Français en tout cas est-ce que
vous encouragez ces mobilisations à ce
moment-là mais moi je respecte le
l'Inter syndical si vous on est dans une
situation assez exceptionnelle c'est à
dire que nous avons une inter syndicale
l'unité syndicale et ça joue dans la
mobilisation des Français aujourd'hui et
qui donne une image et qui agit de
manière totalement coordonnée c'est très
important les dates de l'Inter syndicale
sont les miennes ils ont leur raison
leurs objectifs ils savent ce qu'ils
font il faut aller jusqu'où est-ce qu'il
faut aller jusqu'à bloquer le pays
jusqu'à des grèves reconductibles
jusqu'à des actions comme fait la CGT
énergie ce qui coupe le courant chez
certaines personnes qui le remet chez
d'autres pour qu'ils nous ont été coupés
c'est pas à moi de dire ça c'est pas une
affaire de majorité et d'opposition
c'est une affaire de peuple français et
de président de la République et de
Première ministre et donc les gens iront
jusqu'où ils peuvent aller à condition
qu'il soit soutenu nous le faisons nous
les parlementaires nous le faisons au
Sénat à l'Assemblée nationale et dans la
rue hier et c'est le mouvement social
qui dira avec l'unité syndicale qui est
le talisman de cette mobilisation quelle
va être votre stratégie au Sénat est-ce
que vous pensez pouvoir faire reculer le
gouvernement dans un sénat je le
rappelle la majorité de droite qui est
favorable à cette réforme ce que
j'observe pour le moment c'est que on
est parti en quelques semaines d'un
soutien du groupe irrépublicains de
l'Assemblée à la réforme et que chaque
jour ça s'effrite un peu quand même ce
soutien pour une raison simple c'est que
la droite les républicains est présente
dans les villes moyennes très fortes
dans les villes moyennes en réalité et
les députés les républicains ils ont vu
les manifestations dans leur ville ce
chez moi autant de gens dans la rue
pourquoi je dirais moi prendre des
risques et des retours de bâtons alors
qu'ils sont même qui gouvernent c'est
pas là eux qui ont écrit la réforme donc
on va déjà regarder comment ça se passe
avec les LR à l'Assemblée aujourd'hui
personne ne peut dire c'est le
gouvernement pourra avoir une majorité
dans l'assemblée ou s'il devra recourir
aux 49-3 je vois dans mon département
les députés LR ils ont déjà fait ils ont
déjà fait savoir que une voterai pas
cette réforme donc on va on va regarder
où ils en seront à l'Assemblée et puis
après on verra l'impact que ça aura sur
les LR du Sénat d'une part que aussi
l'impact que ça aura sur le gouvernement
vous savez moi j'ai vu de j'ai un petit
peu de d'histoire en la matière j'ai vu
des gouvernements retirer des projets de
loi après le vote du projet de loi au
Parlement donc tout est ouvert mais il a
l'air à l'Assemblée nationale ils ont
une ligne rouge maintenant ils disent
que ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
avant 21 ans doivent se voir appliquer
les 43 annuités mais pas le critère de
la geste que ça c'est un compromis
acceptable pour vous on en est ce n'est
pas à moi de donner les compromis
mouvement syndique c'est un inter
syndical c'est au syndicat de le dire
si ça arrive comme ça la question moi je
me pose des questions vous savez quand
elles arrivent devant moi là pour le
moment cette question là elle est pas
posée le texte n'est pas encore au
scénario on sait pas même on sait même
pas comment il va sortir de l'Assemblée
en terme de procédure en terme de
rédaction donc on va on va attendre de
voir ce qui se passe parce que vous nous
parlez de ces Français qui disent qu'ils
veulent pas travailler plus longtemps
est-ce que il y a pas aussi beaucoup de
Français qui sont obligés de travailler
plus longtemps parce qu'ils doivent
faire leurs 43 annuités et ça ça a été
mis en place par un gouvernement
socialiste oui mais avec les carrières
longues et avec les critères de
pénibilité j'entends le gouvernement
dire c'est une réforme qui sera positive
pour les gens qu'on commençait tôt ou
qu'on des métiers pénibles je vous
rappelle qu'en 2017 ils ont supprimé
trois des quatre critères de pénibilité
quand on discute avec les infirmières
par exemple ou les professions du
médico-social des femmes qui ont passé
leur vie à soulever des malades et
qu'elles expliquent la difficulté
qu'elles ont à faire prendre en compte
leurs conditions de travail dans les
critères de pénibilité c'est sûr que là
il y a des un vrai moyen d'amélioration
est-ce que ça suffira je ne sais pas
parce que je vois quand même très
nettement que pour tous les gens qu'on
travaillait jeunes ou sont des métiers
pénibles il considère qu'à 58 60 ans
beaucoup d'entre eux sont fatigués et
usés donc tout ça est dans le débat et
je pense par ailleurs qu'une partie de
ce débat va avoir lieu certes à
l'Assemblée nationale mais une autre
partie dans la concertation entre le
gouvernement les organisations
syndicales on va parler d'un autre point
d'inquiétude et vous l'avez sans doute
entendu dire dans les mobilisations
c'est quel impact de cette réforme pour
les femmes et pour en parler on va aller
retrouver Jean-Marc chevaucher vous
connaissez bien rédacteur en chef
adjoint du Courrier Picard qui est votre
presse locale le rentre Rossignol
bonjour Jean-Marc merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous et Jean-Marc vous souhaitiez
justement revenir sur un aspect de cette
réforme la retraite des femmes
oui on peut en parler parce que Laurence
Rossignol est intervenu là-dessus au
Sénat il y a quelques jours après les
propos de Franck Riester qui avait admis
que cette réforme allait demander aux
femmes un effort supplémentaire alors
Laurence Rossignol vous connaissez très
bien le sujet Olivier du soft vous a
répondu sur l'âge de suppression de la
décote maintenu à 67 ans et vous a
répondu sur une retraite minimum à
laquelle dont elle pourrait bénéficier
200000 personnes sans doute et sans
doute à peu près deux tiers de femmes et
vous votre position c'est de dire que
les femmes en ont un petit peu assez de
devoir s'adapter en permanence et que
vous souhaiteriez que que qu'elle soit
un petit peu mieux considérée dans alors
ma question c'est
jusqu'où quel serait les vos exigences
pour pour que ce projet de loi vous le
considériez favorable
aux femmes
d'abord retrait du reportage à 64 ans
parce que les femmes vont devoir
travailler plus longtemps alors à ça le
gouvernement répond oui mais comme tout
le monde comme les hommes il faut bien
falloir qu'elle fasse un effort
supplémentaire un effort comme les
hommes en réalité les experts ont
projeté ce que d'ailleurs l'un des
études d'impact n'a pas fait on a une
antenne d'impact qui est quand même
assez misérable les vont projeter les
conséquences de la réforme sur les
femmes et on s'aperçoit que les femmes
vont devoir travailler
deux fois plus longtemps que les hommes
vont devoir le faire je fais simple pour
une femme né en 72 elle va devoir
travailler huit mois de plus pour un
homme né en 72 c'est 4 mois de plus donc
l'effet de l'allongement du reportage il
est plus fort sur les femmes que sur les
hommes donc déjà si on si on retire le
reportage à 74 ans déjà on gagne quelque
chose pour les femmes en plus le texte
ne va pas assez loin
la prise en compte des carrières hachées
le gouvernement nous parle d'un minimum
à 1200 euros mais les conditions d'accès
au minimum de 1200 euros elles sont
quand même assez exigeantes puisque il
faut à la fois une carrière complète et
avoir été au SMIC toute sa vie
en les femmes peuvent répondre peuvent
répondre à la deuxième condition d'avoir
été hospito de leur vie les hommes moins
c'est vrai parce que en fait souvent les
gens comme un petit peu de progression
de carrière mais en revanche rares sont
celles qui ont la carrière complète
sinon elles sont dans un schéma de
retraite normal pour ça il prend des
carrières hachés et la deuxième chose
c'est que le miam contributif il y a
deux morceaux un morceau de base un
morceau complémentaire sur le morceau
complémentaire faux 20 20 ans et en plus
on ne compte pas ni les trimestres de
maternité ni les trimestres de congé
parental ni tout ça donc il faut
maintenant la question qui est posée
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait du temps de
travail gratuit des femmes
parce que c'est du travail gratuit que
les femmes ont fait à la maison en
élevant les enfants on s'occupant de des
vieux parents ou des vieux beaux-parents
en s'occupant des malades qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de ce temps de travail
gratuit des femmes dans la prise en
compte de la retraite et on peut faire
beaucoup mieux le gouvernement dit pas
la même chose que vous hier Gabriel
Attal redisait que aujourd'hui les
femmes partent à la retraite après les
hommes qu'avec cette réforme elle
partiront avant et que la revalorisation
des petites pensions ça profite deux
fois plus aux femmes qu'aux hommes
n'êtes pas d'accord avec ça non mais la
question n'est pas de sincère profite
deux fois plus au vin de côté je crois
que c'est François Ruffin qui a dit que
c'est trop valorisation allait profiter
à 48 personnes alors j'imagine que le
chiffre était volontairement provocateur
mais entre c'est au-dessus de 48 mais
est-ce que c'est beaucoup au dessus de
48 on n'en sait rien je redis le double
critère d'avoir une carrière complète ça
élimine beaucoup beaucoup des femmes
aujourd'hui 70% des gens qui ont moins
de 1000 euros de retraite par mois ont
des faire un complète leur carrière vont
être toujours aussi incomplètes après la
réforme qu'aujourd'hui et ne seront pas
accessibles à cette revalorisation dont
nous parle donc que le gouvernement
continue de raconter que c'est une bonne
réforme pour les femmes et quand même
une supercherie Jean-Marc un dernier mot
rapidement
mais on peut parler de la mobilisation
en Picardie au sujet de cette réforme
des retraites et notamment dans l'Oise
Laurence Rossignol vous en a parlé tout
à l'heure si mille personnes à Compiègne
c'est effectivement les chiffres qu'a
donné le Courrier Picard ce matin donc
on a les mêmes que Madame Rossignol on
n'a pas forcément les mêmes que la
police ou les manifestants mais nous
avons nous avons les mêmes ou alors
madame Rossignol et bonne victoire et
5000 abonnés ce qui effectivement pour
le département de l'Oise représente des
chiffres importants parce que on n'a pas
vu des chiffres aussi importants depuis
de très grandes manifestations sociales
du essentiellement à l'usine
continentale par exemple oui c'est ça un
dernier mot Laurence
dans l'Oise il y avait aussi une
manifestation à Creil également avec je
crois que c'est 2500 personnes à Creil
la semaine dernière on a vu la
Pont-Sainte-Maxence bon toute l'Oise est
plus Gabin toute la Picardie y compris
des petites villes les sous-préfectures
sont mobilisés les gens manifestent au
plus près de chez eux il y a la manif de
proximité qui est aujourd'hui très
fréquentée qu'il a été hier et je pense
que les gens vont continuer de se
mobiliser et quelqu'un m'amusait hier en
me disant vous savez madame rossialsi
continue de nous insulter tous les
week-ends comme a fait Darmanin dans Le
Parisien cette semaine on va revenir
toutes les semaines nous hein c'est pas
comme ça c'est pas comme ça qu'on va
régler le problème et c'est la une du
Courrier Picard la rue maintient la
pression c'est à la Une de votre journal
Jean-Marc merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous Jean-Marc chevaucher et on
suivra bien évidemment la suite de ces
mobilisations face à l'actualité du
Sénat les chargée aujourd'hui on
commence par parler de l'hôpital qui est
en crise également le Sénat examine cet
après-midi complexe pour garantir un
monde minimum de soignants par patience
hospitalisée vous êtes rapporteur de ce
texte on voit tout de suite le détail
avec Marion Vigreux
[Musique]
bonjour Marion bonjour Oriane bonjour
madame Rossignol et Marion on va donc se
pencher avec vous sur cette proposition
de loi qui sera examinée aujourd'hui qui
vise un restaurant minimum de soignants
par patience hospitalisé oui c'est une
proposition qui a été déposée par
Bernard jaumil sénateur socialiste
différente expérience à l'étranger
montrent que plus il y a de soignants
plats par malades plus les bénéfices
sont notables côté patient on observe
par exemple une baisse de la mortalité
des réadmissions et des durées
d'auspectives d'hospitalisation et puis
côté soignant une baisse des cas de Burn
Out et du sentiment d'insatisfaction et
une amélioration de leur motivation et
en matière de démotivation d'ailleurs on
rappelle qu'en France entre 2020 et 2022
on est passé de 10000 à 60 000 postes
vacants d'infirmiers alors des ratios il
en existe déjà ce sont les ratios qui
sont dit sécuritaires pour les services
sensibles comme la néonatologie ou les
soins intensifs et avec cette PPL il
s'agit ici de généraliser ses quotas à
tous les services cette idée elle avait
été soumise au sénateur l'an dernier par
les professionnels de santé lors de la
commission d'enquête sur la situation à
l'hôpital voici par exemple ce que
disait Véronique enghen du collectif
interhôpital une étude scientifique a
démontré que la mortalité des patients
augmentaient dès qu'une infirmière
devait s'occuper de plus de six patients
dans nos hôpitaux il n'est pas rare
qu'une infirmière doit s'occuper de 16
patients en journée voire 24 la nuit
Laurence Rossignol vous dites que lors
de vos auditions les soignants se sont
montrés unanimement favorables assez
ratio en revanche plus de fébrilité la
part des directeurs d'établissements qui
créent pour pour leur finance
bien entendu mais nous la démarche que
nous avons avec Bernard jolimiez et mes
collègues du groupe socialiste et
globalement tout le Sénat parce qu'il
faut dire que cette proposition de loi a
été adoptée à l'unanimité en commission
la semaine dernière et qu'elle sera
adoptée cet après-midi en sciences
publiques ce que nous voulons c'est que
le service public hospitalier y compris
les établissements privés associés au
service public mais non lucratifs envoie
un message au personnel je reviens pas
sur les conditions de travail à
l'hôpital on les connaît la dégradation
des conditions de travail est liée aussi
au désamour et à la fuite des personnels
et en particulier des infirmières parce
que le sujet est pas tout à fait même
pour les infirmières les médecins les
médecins on en manque à une pénurie donc
elle n'a pas beaucoup en dehors de
l'hôpital mais en ce qui concerne les
infirmières il y en a beaucoup en dehors
de l'hôpital aujourd'hui un tiers des
infirmières qui sont sortis de l'école
quittent l'hôpital trois ans après en
gros je vous donne les chiffres elles
sont importants un tiers des élèves des
quitte au milieu des études un tiers ne
va pas travailler dans les hôpitaux à la
fin des études et le troisième tiers qui
va à l'hôpital s'en va au bout de deux
ou trois ans et donc c'est un nouvel en
permanent donc on a quand même un vrai
sujet comment fidéliser comment attirer
les personnels soignants à l'hôpital
alors il y a effectivement les
conditions de rémunération le seigneur
de la santé s'en est partiellement
occupé mais il y a un autre sujet qui
est que la qualité de vie au travail la
qualité du soin que les femmes apportent
c'est souvent quand même bien souvent
des femmes et la capacité à faire le
métier qu'on a choisi correctement et
c'est ça que nous ont raconté les
soignants infirmières comme médecin
c'est que aujourd'hui il n'arrive plus à
travailler d'une manière sécurisée ni
pour eux-mêmes ni pour les soignants
parce que ce qui se passe c'est que dans
les services sont tellement tendus en
termes de personnel une infirmière
crainte ou un problème de santé et
souvent les problèmes de santé sont liés
à l'épuisement
un arrêt de maladie et puis après c'est
un jeu de domino c'est à dire que les
autres assument pendant un temps ça
charge et après c'est plus possible et
on ferme des lits parce que à ceux qui
nous disent oui mais avec vos systèmes
de ratio c'est à dire effectivement de
mettre un nombre minimum de soignants
pour les les patients vous allez aboutir
à des fermetures de lits les fermeture
de lit c'est le cas aujourd'hui c'est la
réalité de l'hôpital c'est confirme des
lits parce qu'on n'a pas de personnel
pour s'en occuper pour s'occuper au pied
du lit comme on dit voilà donc cette
proposition de loi elle a un but c'est
de dire aux soignants revenez à
l'hôpital dans les années à venir on va
vous assurer des conditions de travail
qui vous permettront de faire bien votre
travail
Marion que propose justement les
sénateurs précisément pour définir ces
ratios minimum alors la mission serait
confiée à la Haute Autorité de santé qui
devrait donc définir pour chaque
spécialité en quota minimal de soignants
parler ouvert par nombre de passages
avec une période de validité de 5 ans
permettant de les faire évoluer si
besoin cela est destiné aux hôpitaux
publics et aux établissements de santé
privé d'intérêt collectifs dans votre
rapport Laurence rossinol vous dites que
c'est une appropriation souple qui
serait laissée aux établissements en
fonction des types de patients des
contraintes matérielles mais vous ne
craignez pas justement qu'avec cette
souplesse certains établissements
n'appliquent pas ces recommandations de
quota alors
il a fallu être à la fois déterminé et
adapter au réel L'Oréal c'est qu'on
pouvait pas dire au 1er juillet 2023
tous les tous les services dans tous les
établissements vont être soumis à des
ratios parce que ça n'aurait pas été
possible tout simplement donc moi je
conçois cette loi comme une loi de
programmation pour l'hôpital c'est moi
le programmation de du personnel
hospitalier donc on a deux étapes une
première étape dans deux ans la haute
autorisation
et après la fin de ma chronique allez-y
et non parce qu'on est on est obligé de
travailler en prévision c'est de la
prévision ce qu'on fait et une deuxième
étape 2 ans après qui est celle de
l'application des ratios en écoutant les
soignants
en écoutant les soignants qu'on a que
j'ai auditionné pendant toute une
semaine ce n'est tout le monde les
médecins les infirmières les présidents
de CME des centres hospitaliers et des
centres hospitaliers universitaires les
grands les petits tout en fait j'ai vu
que dans des établissements qui ont déjà
trouvé des formes à elle et je crois pas
qu'il faille faire tomber des chiffres
comme des couperets au mépris de ce que
déjà la culture de du service la culture
de l'établissement a permis de créer
comme organisation
non nous rassions on distingue deux
types de rations les ratios de sécurité
bon c'est ceux qui existent déjà par
exemple en soins critique et puis les
ratios de qualité et effectivement dans
ces ratio de qualité il y a une petite
idée de fourchette alors après ce sera
effectivement dans les établissements et
dans les services une exiger de créer
les conditions bien sûr que de toute
façon il y a pas de système parfait sans
risque si on fait des ratios coup près
et auquel cas il y a un risque de
fermeture de lit si les ratios sont pas
respectés ou si les budgets suivent pas
soit on fait des ratios qualitatifs avec
une petite marge de manœuvre et
d'adaptation et ça permet d'avoir un
objectif et j'ajoute quand même derrière
tout ça c'est que ça va demander du
financement
est aussi un moyen de dire il faut que
l'on dame c'est-à-dire le budget
hospitalier augmente dans les années à
venir pour accompagner cette évolution
de personnes soyons clairs on ne sauvera
pas l'hôpital public à budget identique
et à volume de personnel identique il
faut continuer mettre les moyens et on
propose des moyens des volumes à la
qualité du travail et du soin merci
Marion Laurence rossignolet était très
complète
on a bien compris du coup évidemment ce
qu'il y avait dans ce texte et c'était
le but merci Marion à tout à l'heure
dans le club on va parler de ce qui se
passe du côté de l'Assemblée nationale
autour du référendum sur la réforme des
retraites il y a un autre texte une
autre actualité aujourd'hui au scénar
évidemment importante c'est aujourd'hui
que serait examiné la question du droit
de l'idée à l'IVG dont la Constitution
la constitutionnalisation de l'IVG c'est
la deuxième fois que le Sénat se penche
sur cette question et alors là le
sénateur les républicains Philippe Bas
un peu pris tout le monde de court vous
allez nous le dire puisqu'il a proposé
une nouvelle écriture il propose
d'inscrire dans leur constitution la
phrase suivante la loi détermine les
conditions dans lesquelles s'exerce la
liberté de la femme de mettre fin à sa
grossesse en fait sa substitue la
liberté et la notion de liberté à celle
de droit est-ce que du coup ça vous va
comme rédaction alors c'est une réaction
là n'est pas la nôtre nous nous sommes
dans l'idée d'un droit à l'IVG mais il
est clair que la rédaction de propose
Philippe Bas elle elle desserre l'étau
bien entendu parce que le risque c'est
que la droite sénatoriale nous livre le
même vote que celui qu'elle avait livré
au mois d'octobre et que le texte soit
encore rejeté par le Sénat en proposant
un amendement de ce type Philippe Bas
propose en fait ce qui est de plus
important que l'IVG rentre dans la
Constitution et c'est ça le sujet est-ce
qu'on va inclure l'IVG dans les droits
et libertés fondamentales garanties par
la Constitution pour le protéger pour
l'avenir bien pour la protéger pour
l'avenir
IVG et aussi pour infliger à ceux qui
manifestent encore il y a 8 jours 10
jours à Paris contre la
constitutionnalisation il faut leur dire
que le Parlement ne les suit pas et
c'est ça la question qui est posée
aujourd'hui ça vous a surpris cette
rédaction proposée par Philippe vous
vous y attendiez j'avais entendu dire
que Philippe va trouver que la rédaction
n'était pas bonne qu'il avait qu'on
pouvait faire mieux mais il s'était pas
avancé jusqu'à en proposer une autre il
l'a fait à l'issue de la commission des
lois je pense que l'amendement Philippe
Bas peut sauver l'honneur du Sénat et de
la droite sénatoriale parce que moi j'ai
vu et pourtant je suis identifié comme
étant active sur ce sujet les gens me
dire mais c'est quoi cette histoire le
Sénat pourquoi vous bloquez 80% des
Français sont favorables à la
constitutionnalisation d'IVG pourquoi le
Sénat s'obsine à être le dernier petit
village conservateur de la République et
celui qui bloque la consulatisation et
les gens m'ont interpellé je me pas moi
mais les autres oui et les autres pour
le moment sont majoritaires et je pense
que l'amendement Philippa peut être un
moyen d'avancer vers l'entrée de l'IVG
dans la Constitution pour ma part je
sais que on avance par compromis voilà
c'est cette rédaction n'est pas la vôtre
c'était pas celle ce qui est par la
gauche est-ce que du coup vous pourriez
voter cette rédaction pour passer par
Philippe alors
vous savez en 74 lorsque la Huawei a été
adoptée la gauche était très active à
une défendait le droit à l'IVG pour
autant la proposition le projet doit
veille n'était pas celui qui a gauche je
voulais si la gauche avait voté sa
propre loi il y aurait eu le
remboursement par la sécu il y aurait
pas eu la condition de détresse aurait
pas eu les deux entretiens il y aurait
pas eu la clause de conscience c'était
pas la loi que vous voulez à la gauche
mais la gauche a considérée en 74 que
voter la loi veille d'abord permettait
qu'elle soit adoptée sans la gauche elle
ne l'était pas et bien qu'il y ait des
compromis il n'était mieux d'avancer sur
la base d'un compromis que de refuser un
texte et de reporter à beaucoup plus
tard la légalisation de l'IVG et de
laisser des femmes dans les avortements
clandestins donc on est un peu dans la
toute chose égale par ailleurs on est un
peu dans la même situation qu'en 74 cet
amendement de Philippe Bas ne peut être
adopté que si la gauche le vote
mais ça ne suffit pas pour qu'il soit
adopté il faut qu'une partie de ceux qui
avaient voté contre où c'était abstenus
en octobre vote l'amendement Philippe
Bas pour que le Sénat puisse contribuer
à garantir que
l'ivgal vous pensez pouvoir la journée
de commencer je vous dirai ça ce soir un
dernier mot sur après parce que c'est
pas parce que le Sénat même si le Sénat
le vote aujourd'hui ça veut pas dire que
ça sera influé dans la Constitution le
parcours est encore long le parcours est
encore long puisque ce ne serait pas la
même rédaction que ça a été adopté à
l'Assemblée pour autant ce serait ainsi
une politique fort ça voudrait dire que
en fait les deux assemblées sont prêtes
sous des rédactions différentes mais
sont d'accord pour faire entrer des
végés dans la Constitution vous en
appelez Emmanuel Macron après c'est une
discussion avec le gouvernement parce
que le gouvernement
reconnaissons lui ça c'est que sur le
vote du Sénat il ne peut pas grand chose
mais une fois que le sénor a voté bien
sûr il pourra merci Laurence Rossignol
merci beaucoup d'être venu nous voir ce
matin on a eu beaucoup de sujets à
grosse journée vous reviendrez nous voir
très prochainement je vous les remercie
beaucoup dans 20 minutes on reparlera
évidemment de la mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites dans le club on
ira voir comment ça s'est passé dans nos
régions on sera notamment du côté de
Saint-Etienne et de Poitiers on va en
parler tout de suite avec notre
prochaine invité c'est François Aubry
qui nous rejoint